so my apologies I just had a deviated
septum surgery yesterday
but what we're going to talk about in
this video is the notion of an ion so
before we talk about ions we're just
going to talk about the idea of an
element for example if I have carbon
carbon is an element and let's say I
have one atom of carbon what do we know
about that one atom of carbon well by
definition an atom of carbon has six
protons so it's going to have six
protons and if it is neutral carbon it
is going to have the same number of
electrons it is going to have six
electrons and that's what makes it
neutral you have the six positive
charges and the six negative charges now
you could have a carbon ion although
they aren't that typical the way you get
an ion is if you don't have an equal
amount of protons and electrons so for
example if you had six protons and five
electrons what would that be well we
still have six protons and remember
protons are what define what element
we're dealing with so we're still
dealing with carbon but now we have one
more positive charge that we have a
negative charge so this will be carbon
with you could write it as a one plus
charge like that or you could even write
it like this and this you would just
view as a carbon atom this you would now
call an ion because it has that net
charge it has a different number of
protons and electrons what if you were
to go the other way around
what if you were to have five protons
five protons and six electrons what
would this be I'll remember protons
define what element you're dealing with
so now if you look at what element has
five protons we're dealing with boron
so this is going to be boron neutral
boron will have five protons and five
electrons but this one has one extra
electron so it has one extra negative
charge so you can write it like this one
- or you could just say it has a
negative charge so this is a boron ion
right over here as soon as you have an
imbalance between protons and electrons
you no longer would call it an atom you
would call it an actual ion now let's do
an example question dealing with this so
our question tells us our question our
question tells us an atom and an atom of
platinum has a mass number of 195 so
let's just look up platinum on our
periodic table platinum is sitting right
over here if you could see it so an atom
of platinum has a mass number of 195 and
195 looks pretty close to that atomic
mass we have listed there and it
contains 74 electrons 74 electrons how
many protons and neutrons does it
contain and what is its charge all right
so let's think about this a little bit
so we're dealing with platinum so by
definition platinum has 78 protons so we
know that it has 78 78 protons they cut
they're telling us it has 74 electrons
74 electrons we like electrons so just
from that we see we have four more
protons than electrons so you have you
would have a positive four charge four
more of the positive things that you
have on the elect of the negative things
so you could write this as platinum with
a plus four charge this is a platinum
I on a positive platinum ion the general
term when we're talking about a positive
ion we're talking about a cation that is
a positive positive ion up there when we
talked about boron being negative a
negative ion that is an anion this is
just to get ourselves useful useful used
to some of the terminology but we're not
done answering the question they say an
atom of platinum has a mass number of
195 and it contains 74 electrons how
many protons and neutrons doesn't
contain as what is its charge we figured
out its charge
we know the protons by definition
platinum has 78 protons but what about
its neutrons
well protons plus neutrons it's going to
be equal to our mass number it's going
to be equal to 195 so we have 78 protons
plus I'll say n 4 neutrons is equal to
195 subtract 78 from both sides and what
you get the number of neutrons is equal
to 1/100 let's see if I subtract 70 I'll
get 100 n I'll get 125 minus 8 I have a
hundred and seventeen neutrons so 117
neutrons and we're done but the big idea
is and we say atom when we have the same
number of electrons and protons that's
when we are neutral but as soon as we
become non neutral we have either more
electrons or more protons and this is
true of an atom or molecule we will then
call it an ion and if you want to be a
little bit more specific a positive ion
is called a cation and a negative ion is
called an anion